Okay. Let's see how you did. Let's start here in the center with mutations. The
subject of lesson six. There are five main types. There are duplications,
deletions. There are insertions. There are SNVs and there
are chromosomal translocations. Now, I knew to put them
in this order, not because they were the right
size for the boxes. But because of the arrows
pointing to them from down here. We know the mutations
can be either spontaneous or induced. And the spontaneous mutations are
from things like replication errors which
are causes of duplications, insertions, deletions
and single nucleotide variations or SNVs. Induced mutations are from things like
x-rays and UV rays. UV rays can typically cause SNVs whereas x-rays
cause double stranded DNA breaks and eventually
chromosomal translocations. Mutations themselves are just changes in
the non-coding DNA or the coding DNA. For
refreshers on these topics you can review concepts
of coding DNA in lesson three and
non-coding DNA in lesson four. Mutations in the
coding region of DNA can lead to four
different kinds of mutations. Silent mutations which don't
change the amino acids. Missense mutations which
change the amino acid. Nonsense mutations which change
an amino acid to a stop codon.
Or frameshift mutations which completely throw off the
entire reading frame of a ribosome so that you change many amino acids. Now germ
cells also undergo miosis which we learned
about in the last lesson. And an abnormal
division at miosis can cause aneuploidy, which is
the addition or loss of chromosomes. And again, you
learned about chromosomes in lesson two. Now, the
mutations in germ cells are the major source for
new alleles in the following generations. We've learned
about alleles in lessons three, four and really five
as well. And alleles cause traits which we've
sort of generally talked about in lesson one and
more specifically in lesson five. But
alleles and traits have changes in population
frequencies due to natural selection and
random selection. Hopefully this concept map helps
organize your thoughts on the lesson so keep it handy because you might
want to come back to it as we keep moving along in the course.